[Music]
if both powers are taken according to
their specific content and its
individualization we are presented with
the picture of the translate between
them in their individual forms on the
formal side it is the conflict of the
ethical order and self-consciousness
with unconscious nature and the
contingency stemming from nature the
latter has a right against the former
because this is only true spirit is only
an immediate unity with its substance on
the site of content it is the clash
between divine and human law the youth
comes away from the unconscious spirit
of the family and becomes the
individuality of the community but that
he still belongs to the nature from
which he wrenched himself free as
evidenced by the fact that he emerges in
the contingent form of two brothers each
of whom with equal right takes
possession of the community the
inequality of the earlier and later
birth and inequality which is a natural
difference has no importance for them
when they enter the ethical life of the
community but the government as a
unitary soul or the self of the national
spirit does not tolerate a duality of
individuality and the ethical necessity
of this unity is confronted by the
natural accident of their being more
than one these two brothers therefore
fall into disputes and their equal right
to the power of the state destroy them
both for they were equally wrong looked
at from the human point of view the one
who has committed the crime is the one
who not being an actual possession
attacked the community at the head of
which the other stood well on the other
hand he has right on his side who knew
how to apprehend the other merely as an
isolated individual detached from the
community and taking advantage of his
powerlessness banished him he instruct
only at the individual as such not the
community not at the essence of human
right the community attacked a defendant
by what is merely particular and so
without a substantial content preserves
itself and the brothers bring about
their own destruction through their
reciprocal action for individuality
which for the sake of its being for self
puts the whole into peril has expelled
itself from the community and is the
source of its own destruction the
community however will honor the one who
was found on
but the government the restored unitary
self of the community will punish him
who already proclaimed its devastation
on the walls of the city by depriving
him of the last honor he who wanted Li
attacked the spirits highest form of
consciousness the spirit of the
community must be stripped of the honour
of his entire and finished being the
honor due to the spirit of the departed
in paragraph 473 Hagel is now going to
make reference to these two brothers
that that also play a very important
role in the family and political drama
that stems around Oedipus and his
children we've already brought up the
Antigone the famous play by Sophocles
here we're looking at ed achlys and
polyneices
and their role in the entire thing which
occurs in Aeschylus is seven Against
Thebes which ends up having to be
revised to take into account Sophocles
portrayal of the after effects of their
fighting now before we go into this it's
good to sort of remind ourselves of what
is going on within as I've called it
this family drama so we have Oedipus
himself and immaculate talk about that
because I think people probably know
enough about that already but Oedipus
and Jocasta his mother and wife have
children together one of them is going
to be Antigone who who will be the hero
in of that play and she is going to
offer burial rites to her brother
polyneices who has deprived those rights
why is he deprived those rights because
he and ethically x' are supposed to rule
in Oedipus displays the city of Thebes
but are unable to come to terms and
there's various accounts of why this
takes place Hegel is following the one
we're at achlys and taking power and
holding power and expelling his brother
so his brother goes to the archives that
is the the other Greeks further to the
south leads an army against deeds which
effectively makes him a traitor and he
is trying to take the throne back from
from his brother trying to attain
justice or some sort of balance and his
brother is able to rally the troops they
fight each other they kill each other on
the battlefield as two of the champions
and ethically is given a hero's
ceremonial burial polyneices is left out
by the order of crayon who is their
uncle because he's a traitor to the city
and Antigone then is going to go and
give him his burial rites so here at
this point we're not so much concerned
with Antigone or crayon or even Oedipus
we're interested in the interaction
between these brothers but Hegel says
something very important that I've got
charted out sort of on the board before
that he says if both powers are taken
according to their specific content and
it's individualization specific content
here is the the types of laws and
individualization are the people who are
acting in accordance with those laws he
says we're presented with the picture of
the conflict between them in their
individual forms which lends itself
quite well to dramatization right so he
says on the formal side what we have is
the conflict of the ethical order and
self-consciousness with unconscious
nature and the contingency stemming from
nature now I just have on the board you
know the ethical order and
self-consciousness versus nature but for
Hegel that is something that is integral
to nature there's a kind of contingency
a kinda well it could have been this way
it could have been that way it could be
any old way there's no rhyme or reason
to it although we can come up with
natural laws and that's nice the natural
is not the enemy of the spiritual but it
resists the spiritual and it's always
one step away you might say from undoing
it and on this side the spiritual is the
ethical order but also
self-consciousness because remember
there is no ethical order that remains
in place without the not even
participation or or contribution of
self-consciousness it must become actual
and it only becomes actual through the
individual action and action of course
writ large of individuals together like
saying the government that is self
consciousness so that is what he says
it's happening on
formal level then on the level of
content is what we've been seeing going
on not just throughout this section but
also the previous section the clash
between the divine and human law so now
he says something interesting here
Nature has a right against he says the
former meaning these things over here
why because this is only true spirit it
is only an immediate unity with its
substance it's not completely worked up
if spirit was existing in its full scent
then nature here's sort of what the
promises really wouldn't be able to do
anything against it but nature can
contingency is able to intrude in here
and it's going to do this Hegel says in
terms of these two brothers before we
get there we have the clash between him
and law and divine law he says the youth
comes away from the unconscious spirit
of the family and becomes the
individuality of the community and this
is the movement away from the divine law
into the human law from hiddenness into
openness from the unconscious to the
conscious from the dark to the light of
day you know we've seen all this in
previous paragraphs being discussed at
great length but now Hegel introduces a
new wrinkle it works okay provided that
the youth is one youth but what if you
have to what if you have brothers this
is actually a conflict that played
itself out in multiple places not only
in Greek culture you might think not
just of these two brothers but also of -
and Rhadamanthus or we could even think
in terms of Roman culture and Romulus
and Remus and many other cases where you
have these brothers who are supposed to
share power and for some reason find
themselves incapable of doing so we
might expand this as well - you know
friendships and triumphs irate and and
all these sorts of things where people
are supposed to be
sharing power with each other and that
is supposed to bring about peace justice
prosperity but one of them ends up
taking power so that Hegel sees as a
intrusion of nature into this process so
he tells us that he still belongs to the
nature from which he has wrenched
himself free as evidenced by the fact
that he emerges in the contingent form
of two brothers each of whom with equal
right takes possession of the community
so with a natural order there's going to
be some sort of inequality but it's not
the kind of inequality that really ought
to be playing a role in politics because
you know which of these is the better
brother well that depends on who can
rule for the common good best or
whatever else we're saying count as
justice in this case perhaps you know
the one who can exercise practical
wisdom so as to adjudicate cases most
justly or however we want to define it
in this case one brother gets in charge
because he's older so he says the
inequality of the earlier and later
birth and inequality that is a natural
difference has no difference it has no
importance for them when they enter the
ethical life of the community
but Kiki but here the government is the
unitary Soler the self of national
spirit we saw that those human law has
to be embodied in a particular
government has to be concretize in that
way the government does not tolerate a
duality of individuality there can only
be one boss is another way of saying it
and so it says the ethical necessity
this unity is confronted by the natural
accidents of their being more than one
so the natural accident of their being
more than one introduces this wrinkle it
helps to reproduce the conflict now no
longer in terms of the divine law but in
terms of the human law itself being you
might say turned against itself in the
form of these two brothers it's a little
bit easier than that in part because one
brother does in fact
power and the other one is not holding
power so in this case it's at achlys
according to a lot of the stories who
who takes power first and then when it's
time for his brother to take power says
sorry buddy you're not getting getting
in here as a matter of fact get yourself
out of town because I'm now in charge
and like I said this happened in other
Greek city-states as well so he says the
two brothers fall into dispute and their
equal right to the power of the state
destroys them both for they were equally
wrong why are they equally wrong well on
the part of the one it's wrong for him
to usurp power if they're supposed to be
doing power sharing then they're
supposed to be doing power sharing its
innate an arrangement it's wrong to go
back on that it's wrong to to abrogate
oneself to oneself what belongs
rightfully to one's brother and and both
of them are the sons of Oedipus so both
of them really ought to rule right the
benefactor they're both of the ruling
family because edifis did sound like he
broke a bloodline or anything like that
I mean he in some ways concentrated the
bloodline a little bit more so it's not
as if they shouldn't both be ruling and
so a decrees is wrong the polyneices is
also wrong and he becomes wrong in a way
that the human law is able to identify
and punish so let's see how Hegel
sketches this out he says looked at from
the human point of view the one who has
committed the crime is the one who not
being in actual possession attacks the
community at the head of which the
others stood well on the other hand he
has right on his side who knew how to
apprehend the other merely as an
isolated individual detached from the
community taking advantage of his
powerlessness banished him so at achlys
is the one who's in charge at achlys is
the one that the people of thieves are
looking to and saying hey you gotta save
us from these are guys and it's crazy
brother of yours you know maybe you you
damn or didn't do what you're supposed
to do but hey now he's here with an army
so what's it going to be
so ethically as gets to come across as
the good guy and polyneices is being
treated as a criminal as an isolated
individual as somebody who is going
against the totality of the ethical
order embodied in the human law in the
community going against the government
he goes on and he says the community who
is attacked and defended by what is
merely particular and so without a
substantial content preserves itself
interestingly right both brothers are
becoming mere individuals and they
destroy each other in the process
looking for you know the narrative that
Hegel is telling and lucky for Sophocles
right because it does not occur in every
single case you know Romulus wins Remus
loses
- wins Rhadamanthus loses right but he
goes on and he says they bring about
their own destruction through their
reciprocal action individuality which
for the sake of its being for self put
the whole in peril has expelled itself
from the community and is the source of
its own destruction
notice what Hegel is saying there being
for self understanding one's own place
one's own position what one is that's
part of what's being worked out here
it's not a mere power struggle it's a
question of the meaning of one's
existence and these people are using
political power and military power as a
medium by which to do that and the
community itself you know is somewhat in
awe
and horror over this sort of occurrence
which happens again all the time in
ancient Greek and and so many other
ancient histories and continues on to
our own day this is the sort of thing
that happens in many other modalities as
well and so both of them placed
themselves at a kind of risk of being
seen by the community as criminals as
transgressors as outside of the human
law at
these happen to have the government you
know so he says the community will honor
the one who is found on its side at
achlys in this case but the government
the restored unitary self of the
community who's going to be in this case
not ethically is anymore but crayon his
uncle will punish him who already
proclaimed its devastation on the walls
of the city by depriving him of the last
honor the rights of the debt which is
going to provoke Antigone's action on
behalf of the divine law Polynices is
going to be left out there his corpse
pray for wolves crows whatever
scavengers want to come along and eat it
up so he says he who want only attacked
the spirit eyes form of consciousness
the spirit of the community must be
stripped of the honor of his entire and
finished being the honor due to the
spirit of the departed now we saw this
discussed in the previous section where
we were talking about brother and sister
and the working within the family and
the totally finished individual as being
finished by being given these funerary
rites which remember once again to bring
this full circle was a way of taking
something away from mere nature and
bringing it into the realm of the
ethical thereby the realm of spirit
but it's the universal that easily
knocks off the very tip of the pyramid
and indeed carries off the victory over
the rebellious principle of pure
individuality that is the family it is
merely entered on a conflict with the
divine law a conflict of self-conscious
spirit with what is unconscious for the
latter is the other essential power and
is therefore not destroyed but merely
wronged by the conscious spirit but it
has only the bloodless shade to help it
in actually carrying out its law in the
face of the power and authority of that
other publicly manifest law being a law
of weakness and darkness it therefore at
first that comes to the powerful law of
the upper world for the power of the
former is affected in the underworld not
on earth but the outwardly actual which
is taken away from the inner world its
honor and power has and so doing
consumed its own essence the publicly
manifest spirit has the root of its
power in the nether world the self
certainty and self assurance of a nation
possesses the truth of its oath which
binds all into one solely in the mute
unconscious substance of all in the
waters of forgetfulness
thus it is is that the fulfillment of
the spirit of the upper world is
transformed into its opposite and it
learns that its supreme right is a
supreme wrong that it's victory is
rather its own downfall the dead whose
right is denied knows therefore how to
find instruments of dungeons which are
equally effective and power fullness of
power which is injured it these powers
are other communities whose altars the
dogs or birds defiled with the corpse
which is not raised into unconscious
universality by being given back as its
due to the elemental individuality that
is the earth but remains above ground in
the realm of outer reality it has now
required as a force of divine laws self
conscious real universality they rise up
in hostility and destroy the community
which is dishonored and shattered its
own power the sacred claims of the
family
when reading paragraphs
or 74 one is almost tempted to talk in
Freudian terms of what what Freud called
the return of the repressed which was
things coming out of the unconscious
that have been pushed into their had
been repressed into the unconscious and
then would come forward for the
individual in usually rather unseemly
and disconcerting ways that would
necessitate some psychotherapy Hegel is
actually talking about something that
has somewhat different dynamic in this
case because he isn't just talking about
an individual and the the workings of
the whatever we want to call them the
parts of their soul or psyche or their
faculties anything along those lines
instead he's talking in terms of these
two ethical laws and their
representatives and the counter action
that is provoked on the part of the
divine law which notice by the end of
this is going to take place not through
the agency of the individual turning
against himself but other individuals
and indeed other political communities
coming on the scene so there's a much
broader dynamic happening here than
merely individual psychopathology so he
tells us he's referring back to the what
happened in the previous paragraph where
addict leads had had you know fought
polyneices ethically had taken power and
then Creon is going to punish Polynices
Crayon on part of the government
polyneices of the the individual II says
is if the universal love easily knocks
off the tip of the pyramid and carries
off the victory over the rebellious
principle of pure individuality
what is that rebellious principle of
pure individuality the family in this
case he says it is merely entered on a
conflict with the divine law a conflict
of self-conscious spirit with what is
unconscious and he says for the latter
is the other essential power the divine
law is operating you might say in the
dark
in a catholic' subterranean way that
turns out to be of incredible importance
and can't be adequately taken into
account by those who are ruling in the
light those who are running the show and
are in the limelight so to speak they
can't see out of that circle of the
light so it's almost like somebody who's
up on stage and cannot see the audience
because the brightness of the lights
upon them so he says the the divine law
is not destroyed but merely wronged by
the conscious spirit and he says at
first it doesn't appear to have that
much going for it that's why it looks
like this side has been victorious he
talks about the bloodless shade right
the bloodless shade is all that it has
to help it in carrying out its law in
face of the power and authority of the
other publicly manifest law so Hegel
here calls it a law of weakness and
darkness and he says it at first sub
comes to the powerful law of the upper
world for the power of the former is
effective in the underworld but the
divine law is effective in the
underworld you can threaten people look
when you die you know Hades is going to
treat you really bad he's going to make
you roll a boulder up the hill or you
know make you be in water up to your
neck and every time you stoop down to
drink it it's going to vanish away from
you and the tyrants the you know the
people who are able to take power and
use the the human law and the government
to their advantage they can say well
screw that I'll worry about that when
that time comes there's nothing you can
do to me right now
Zeus or Hades or Ares or whoever alright
so how does this change Hegel says the
outwardly actual which is taken away
from the inner world that's honor and
power has consumed its own essence
that's a very important turning point
the outwardly actual the veer click the
the what shows itself as B
in power by dishonouring by attempting
to push away and reduce the divine law
and those who represent it it has
undercut its own substance why is that
because according to Hegel the divine
law is actually what is lying at the
basis of the very capacity the very
possibility for effective government at
all or a human law in place at all
so Hegel is going to talk here in really
interesting terms
he says the publicly manifest spirit has
the root of its power in the nether
world what we're talking about here is
not just civil religion you know where
we have a religion that essentially
holding things together politically the
way that you know a lot of Roman priests
actually looked at Roman religion all
you have to do is read Cicero
to see that that's the case you know
Rita is on divination or on the nature
of the God and you'll realize that a lot
of the rituals that were being done
we're supposed to provide a kind of
public framework of meaning we we also
talk about this in terms of American
civil religion the French Revolution
attempted to establish something like
that as well a religion of reason
actually the great positivist Auguste
Comte tried to create something like
that as well we're not talking about
that we're talking about something more
primal something more original that is
underlying the human law and giving it
its force so he says the self certainty
and self assurance of a nation possesses
the truth of its oath which binds all
into one solely in the mute unconscious
substance of all in the waters of
forgetfulness so when you undercut the
divine law when you try to marginalize
it when you try to push it completely
out when you try to get rid of it when
you try to make everything manifest as a
totality you end up undercutting the
very
thing that gives the energy that gives
the drive that gives the hidden support
that provides the unity to the human law
here we're starting to look less like
Freud and more like Nietzsche's account
of what the socratic did in his birth of
tragedy
although this is you know many decades
before that that Hegel is is recounting
this now Hegel will say he goes on it's
the fulfillment of the spirit of the
upper world is transformed into its
opposite and it learns that it's supreme
right is the supreme wrong it's victory
is its downfall here we have a
dialectical turning point it learns not
only does it does it have imposed upon
itself but it learned that it is lost in
winning Crayon is going to learn this in
the the you know play itself the
Antigone after he decides to repent and
comes back and Antigone has actually
killed herself and all of his fortunes
are essentially ruined and he's left of
the city that is not only in terrible
mourning but without a successful line
his own son if I remember right also
kills himself so he says the dead whose
right is denied no knows therefore how
to find instruments of vengeance which
are equally effective and powerful as
the power that is injured it it was a
mistake to thank that human government
because it has the world of the light
and has the city is more powerful than
the underworld and everything else that
that environment it that can break
through at any moment so now notice what
he says here it's not just like I said
it's not just a return of the repressed
this isn't just happening only within
the single city here Hegel talks about
other communities he says these powers
are others other communities whose
altars the dogs or birds defiled with
the corpse which is not raised into
unconscious in universality by being
given back as it's due to the elemental
individuality but remains above-ground
in the realm of outer reality and is now
acquired as a
to divine law of self-conscious real
universality something else is being
brought to the fore they rise up in
hostility and destroy the community
which is dishonored and shattered its
own power the sacred claims of the
family you can find others to champion
the family that has been wronged the
divine law that has been repressed so
there there is a return of the repressed
here but it's a return that's coming in
with allies from without allies who
themselves our political communities
have the the chance to embody spirit
that's different than simply a dynamic
that's closed off within itself so that
is what is taking place up to this point
you